good morning Hank it's Tuesday so you
may have noticed that as years go 2016
has been you know something of a
dumpster fire and yet there's still a
lot of good news around the world we
tend to hear about the bad news a lot
because it happens suddenly and it's
often dramatic whereas good news usually
happens slowly like as Max Rosa from our
world and data put it you never see
headlines reading global child mortality
fell by zero point zero zero seven one
nine percent since yesterday but there
is lots of encouraging news let's start
there actually child mortality continues
to fall around the world and 2016 is on
pace to have the fewest child deaths of
any year in like thousands of years
literally then there's Ebola remember
the Ebola virus outbreak that killed
more than 11,000 people in Guinea Sierra
Leone and Liberia it has ended although
flare-ups remain possible and
strengthening community health centers
in those countries is vital to prevent
future outbreaks speaking of ending we
are very very close to ending the
debilitating and extremely painful
guinea worm disease there were about 3.5
million cases as recently as 1986 in
2015 there were 22 cases so far in 2016
there have been seven and then there's
malaria which continues to be a massive
global health problem but the attention
and funding it's received in the last 15
years has made a huge difference around
the world malaria deaths have fallen by
almost half since 2000 we're also making
progress when it comes to non-infectious
diseases like a large phase three study
just found a better treatment for
pancreatic cancer in early stage
pancreatic cancer survival rates are now
approaching 30 percent whereas a decade
ago they were under 10 percent and
overall cancer survival rates are also
going up like in the u.s. in 1980 the
overall cancer survival rate was just
under 50 percent today it's very close
to 70% in fact it might even reach that
milestone this year ok let's move on to
war so worldwide conflict deaths were
down in 2015 from 2014 and they're on
pace to be down again this year this is
largely due to decreases in violence in
Afghanistan and from the Boko Haram
insurgency I want to be clear though
that 2016 is still a definite dumpster
fire when it comes to conflict it's just
that it was worse in 2015 and worse than
that in 2014 but it is worth noting that
worldwide the percentage of humans who
died in war has gone way way way down
since 1945 also Isis is losing they've
lost the cities of Fallujah and manbij
and while they definitely remain a
threat especially in Syria Iraq
Olivia to quote the economist the
self-proclaimed Islamic state is
weakening fast okay let's move on to
bankruptcy there is less of it at least
in the u.s. in fact the rate of personal
bankruptcies has fallen every year since
2010 and is down again in 2016
meanwhile the global economy is growing
and will probably grow faster this year
than it did last year and worldwide
absolute poverty is declining in fact in
2016 there are 200 million fewer people
living in absolute poverty than there
were just four years ago in 2012
literacy rates are going up around the
world and the literacy gender gap is
shrinking the percentage of literate
humans will be higher than ever this
year and no people have not stopped
reading books in fact sales at
bookstores are up in 2016 it's the first
time they've risen in many years and
nobody knows quite why it's happening
but it reminds me that I should really
finish that book I've been working on
we're gonna add with a few fun ones
video games are getting better like I
know lots of people don't like it but I
am overwhelmed by the beauty and size of
the new video game no man's sky in fact
Hank I've just begun a new series on
Hank games where I explore my own
existential anxieties while walking
around a largely abandoned planet you
can watch that by clicking here there's
a link in the doobly-doo but in general
video games have gotten awesome
what else we got more Harry Potter AFC
Wimbledon is in League One and our
awesome new advertising is up in their
Stadium Pokemon Go has led me to explore
a fascinating and intricately detailed
world called outside and Beyonce
released maybe the best non Mountain
Goats album of the decade Hank again I'm
not trying to say that everything is
going well here on earth there is much
to lament and much that needs to change
but I'm really encouraged that as a
species we've shown an ability to make
broad positive changes and I really
believe that in spite of it all hope is
not misguided Hank I'll see you on
Friday